نبيل احمد هزيم في تل ابيب اصداء الهدنه
لدى الاسرائيليين
كما في غزه هدوء حذر هدوء يبدو ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه باتت تعتمد على ان هذا
الاتفاق
سيثبت وقف اطلاق النار سيثبت بلد تتخذ بعض
الاجراءات لطمانه الداخل الاسرائيلي منها
رفع الحواجز وفتح الطرقات في القريبه وفي
قريبه من قطاع غزه وفي محيطه اصدار بعض
التعليمات للبلدات والمستوطنات في غلاف
غزه برفع القيود جزئيا بدايه من السادسه
صباحا ورفعها كليا من منتصف النهار هذا
مؤشر على ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه على ان
اسرائيل ترى بان هذا الاتفاق سيثبت بانها
مطمئنه الى ثبات هذا الاتفاق والالتزامها
به والتزام الفصائل الفلسطينيه به رغم
الخروقات التي شابته بعد دقائق من دخوله
حيز التنفيذ لكن بعد هذا الهدوء التي يسعى
اليه المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي توقفت حياته
كثيرا اثر هذا هذه المعركه واثراء سقوط
الصواريخ على عدد من البلدات وعدد من
المدن الاسرائيليه منها في محيط تل ابيب
ومحيط مدينه القدس وفشل منظومتي القبه
الحديديه ومقلاع داوود في اعتراض الصواريخ
الفلسطينيه التي تطلقها المقاومه من قطاع
غزه هناك اسئله كثيره ستفتح صباح غدا
الاحد عندما تبدا وسائل الاعلام بطرح هذه
التساؤلات ويبدا السياسيون
والمسؤولون السابق العسكريون الذين عاده
ما يبدلون بدلوهم في هذه الامور من طرح
تساؤلات حول مدى فعاليه منظومتي قبه القبه
الحديديه ومقلاع داوود وايضا المساله
السياسيه في اختيار نتنياهو وحكومه
الزنياهو التوقيت
لشن عقارات لشني عمل سلسله من الاغتيالات
لقاده في سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
التابع لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
والجوله العدوان التي تلتها والتراشق
بينها بين اسرائيل وبين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه على مد الايام الخمسه الماضيه
وحكمت التهم الخجوله بالتصريح احيانا
بالهمس احيانا اخرى من ان نتنياهو اراد ان
يصدر ازمته الداخليه الى فتح جبهه مع
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في القطاع ستعود ازمه
الداخليه الى الظهور مجددا كانت هناك
اليوم مظاهرات خجوله اعداد ليست بالكبيره
كالعاده لمظاهرات كل سبت تشريها المعارضه
احتجاجا على مشروع التغيير القضائي الذي
يسعى نتنياهو ائتلافه من اقصى اليمين في
تمريره في الكنيست هذه الاحتجاجات ستعود
مره اخرى الجلل حول هذا الموضوع سيعود مره
اخرى في الداخل الاسرائيلي لكن بشكل عام
الهدوء في هذه الجوله من جولات العدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه سيكون صداها
مرحبا به في الشارع الاسرائيلي الذي تعطلت
حياتي حياته كثيرا بالامس كانت مدينه تل
ابيب شبه فارغه يوم صباحا كانت مدينه تل
ابيب ليس ك عادتها من الاكتضاض الان
المجتمع الاسرائيلي سيعود الى حياته
الطبيعيه
بانتظار وبامل ان تستمر هذه الهدنه ويستمر
وقف اطلاق النار وستعود ستعود الحكومه
الاسرائيليه او الائتلاف الحاكم
الاسرائيلي بقياده سينياهو واحزاب اقصى
اليمين المتحالفه معه الى ازماتها
الداخليه مع المعارضه احمد هزيمه من تل
ابيب شكرا